One should be satisfied with the fact that
we have achieved what we have achieved.
It's not nothing.
Hi There, Steve Kaufmann here.
Uh, today I want to talk about
perfectionism in language learning.
If you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe, click on
the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
Now, what do I mean by perfectionism?
I think I, I could also turn
perfectionism in language learning,
the sort of the desire to perform.
How did I do?
I've compared that urge to sort of
be judged or the fear to be judged.
It's sort of like a, an Olympic
diver and to me, language learning
is very different from Olympic
diving or any kind of performance.
We learn languages in
order to communicate.
So this might mean in order to understand
the movie in order to watch a series on
Netflix and get a sense of some, maybe
distorted sense of the culture, but
nevertheless, to enjoy that experience,
to understand, and also to communicate,
to speak, communicate ideas, communicate
feelings, it's all about communication.
So now of course we would all like
to speak, you know, as well as
we can, as correctly as we can.
And to that extent, it is useful to
every now and again, study grammar.
Uh, because there are things when we
just listen and read that we don't notice
in the language, I've said this before.
Some things have to be pointed out to us.
And even after they're pointed out
to us, we still won't get them right.
I mean, again, we've had this experience
of correcting a mistake and making the
same mistake again and again and again.
And the reason that happens is because
in my mind, the process of learning
a language is a process of creating
new neural connections in the brain.
Uh, the brain establishing some patterns,
uh, us slowly getting used to this new
language, but we get used to it, or we get
accustomed to it in a very individual way.
It's very much influenced
by our native language.
Uh, and so some people are going to,
you know, acquire a, a series of habits
in the language that might be, uh,
with better pronunciation or worst
pronunciation, or more grammatically
correct or less grammatically correct.
While we want to get better, we
shouldn't be so worried about how
we're doing, worried about how
we're being judged that we miss the
main goal, which is communication.
Uh, and, and I, the reason I bring this up
right now is becasue amongst the comments
here, someone said, oh, Steve, you know...
in fact I get those quite often...
you say you speak 20 languages.
In fact, you don't.
The other day you spoke Italian and you
were very rusty and so forth and so on.
True.
And there are languages that I have
spoken and I would have trouble
speaking right now, at least initially,
but those are still languages that
I have invested a lot of time into.
Those are languages, like say Korean,
where I'm not at all happy at my
ability to produce the language or
even to understand the language.
I have, at least on our count at
LingQ a large, uh, passive vocabulary.
I understand how the language works, the
structures in the language, because I've
seen these patterns so many, many times,
but I haven't been using it and therefore
I can't speak it very well if at all.
Uh, well I can speak
it, but not very well.
And, uh, but if I were to go to Korea,
it wouldn't take me a day or two before
I would be able to speak fairly well.
When I was in Greece or Prague or
Romania, I was also communicating.
Communicating, not
perfectly, but communicating.
So languages that we learn to a degree,
which is less than perfect, those are
still languages that we have learned
to some extent, we have enjoyed
learning, we have discovered bits of.
And if that is true for languages that I
don't speak as well as I would like, say
Italian, which might be my 10th language.
It's also true for someone who is
learning their first foreign language.
In other words, it's always not
quite as good as we would like.
However, it's very much a personal thing.
It's your foreign language.
It's your English, it's your
Italian, it's your Spanish.
And one should be satisfied
with the fact that we have
achieved what we have achieved.
It's not nothing, even though
we would all like to improve.
And that's another reason why
we've had this debate before here
about pitch accent in Japanese.
I lived in Japan for nine years.
I've been speaking
Japanese for 40, 50 years.
Never even knew until recently that
there was such a thing as pitch accent.
It never prevented me from communicating.
I do not believe the Japanese
people by and large are bothered
by someone who has improper pitch
accent, whatever that might mean.
Um, we don't need to seek perfection.
We don't need to.
There's nothing wrong with
aspiring to achieve perfection.
There's nothing wrong with focusing
on one language and trying to be as
accurate with the grammar as possible,
trying to get pitch accent, write
in Japanese and all of these other
things, but it's not necessary.
And if you don't do those things,
you can still enjoy the language.
You can still say you speak the
language, uh, because you know,
performing to a degree of perfection
is a very limited aspect of what's
involved in learning a language.
And I think to the extent that people are
concerned about nailing these things down,
it probably inhibits them and it reduces
the enjoyment of language learning.
It makes us less likely to engage with
the language, to speak the language.
And we all know that the more we
engage with the language, the more we
listen, the more we read, the more we
speak, the more we make mistakes, the
more we're going to improve in time.
So, uh, I just mention that because people
often say, well, you say speak 20...
You say you speak 20 languages, but
you're not very good at any of them.
And yeah, I'm not going to
be as good in 20 languages as
someone who focuses on one.
And there's always people who are
better than me, better than you.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't take away from the
enjoyment that we can all achieve in
learning one or more foreign language.
So that's what I had to say about
the pursuit of perfectionism.
Thank you for listening.